[موسيقى]
نحن
في قلب موقع إكسبو النابض
، فهذه هي ساحة الوصل ، وهذا هو المكان الذي سيجتمع فيه الناس
خلال هذا
الحدث الذي يستمر ستة أشهر ، ما يمكن أن نتوقعه جيدًا
ما نأمله حقًا
هو عندما يفعل الناس  يجتمعون في هذه الحديقة
حيث يرون
عرضًا هائلاً أنه عندما يأتون إلى
موقع المعرض ، فإن لديهم الفرصة
لتجربة واستكشاف بلدان من
جميع أنحاء العالم حاضرون جميعًا
هنا أيضًا
، ويستخدمون هذا حقًا كفرصة
لرسم المسار  إلى الأمام
لما سيبدو عليه العامان
المقبلان ، بعد ثلاثة أشهر ونصف ،
ما زلنا في أزمة مرغوبة ،
كيف سيؤثر ذلك على
تجربة الزائر ، لذلك أولاً ،
تعتبر سلامتهم أمرًا بالغ الأهمية ، أعني أننا
لا نتنازل عن ذلك
في  كل ما نؤمن به أيضًا أن
هناك ما يكفي من العلم
وهناك مقاييس كافية
تُظهر أن ارتداء القناع الخاص بك
بعيدًا عن تجربة اللمس
والتطعيم
والتهوية المناسبة سيساعد حقًا
بشكل كبير في ضمان أن هذه
بيئة آمنة ،
كان هدفك هو 25 مليون
زيارة هو هذا الهدف ، لذلك نحن
حريصون جدًا
على تحقيق هدف 25 مليون زيارة من
المحتمل أن يكون مزيجنا
مختلفًا بعض الشيء وبالتأكيد في
البداية
سنعتمد أكثر قليلاً على
الزيارات المحلية بدلاً من
الأطروحة الدولية
بعد أن قلنا إننا نعتقد
أنه سيكون هناك انتعاش جيد جدًا ، حيث
ترى بالفعل القليل من ذلك الآن
في الصيف ،
هذا ليس جيدًا  مشروع بنية تحتية رخيص
، جاء بتكلفة حوالي
سبعة
مليارات دولار ، وسيعمل
إكسبو 2020 على تحقيق الصالح
العام لدبي والإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لم يكن الاستثمار
لبناء
معرض ، كان الاستثمار في إنشاء مدينة جديدة
في المستقبل ،
وهذا هو 480  موقع هكتار
متصل جيدًا بك تعرف
بنية تحتية من الدرجة الأولى مع تقنية 5G
، الأمر المثير للاهتمام بالنسبة لي على المستوى الشخصي
هو أنني أرى كيف ظهرت التقنيات الجديدة
نتيجة kovac ، هناك
المزيد من التركيز على ag tech ، وهناك المزيد
من التركيز على التكنولوجيا الحيوية ،
وهناك صناعات جديدة يمكن أن تحقق
قيمة أكبر للاقتصاد ،
وهذا هو المكان المثالي لتتمكن من
القيام بذلك.